I am about $130,000 in debt um on what
and a lot of it is uh well the majority
is my truck and my wife's car which is
how much each um the truck is 40,000 and
the wife's car is at
15,000 is only 30,000 a year right now
you said 30,000 what yes your income is
30k yes um I quit my business because I
was going through a struggle for a short
period of time and I I decided that I'm
going to quit go for a job and it didn't
work out so I started my I started a new
company until your business is making
you enough money to float your lifestyle
it's really just a hobby or a side
hustle and I commend you for starting
that business but it's not making enough
money to to manage your household bills
obviously